It started offering something very different: streaming content.
The model was wildly successful.
Netflix was a phenomenon.
TV was dead.
It was all about subscriptions.
Here in Silicon Valley,...
...Netflix has just released its new audience figures for the last quarter,...
...and they're not especially good.
They lost a million subscribers in the last three months.
So what's gone wrong?
For one, there is simply loads of competition.
Disney Plus, Amazon Prime, HBO Max, Apple TV, to name but a few...
...and that competition has created a brutal spending war.
The top eight streamers are predicted to spend...
...more than 100 billion dollars on content this year.
Netflix has come up with some monster hits in recent times.
Think Squid Games, The Crown...
...and Netflix productions were nominated for 27 Oscars this year.
The company is still making good content,...
...but the cost of living crisis has led to belt-tightening,...
...with families across the world looking at streaming services...
...as a potential saving.
Many other households don't have a Netflix account at all,...
...but share the login of friends or family.
One study found that Netflix was losing 25 billion dollars a year...
...from people watching Netflix on someone else's account.
But Netflix has known about this problem for years...
...and hasn't been able to stop it from happening.
Instead, Netflix is now looking at adverts as a potential solution.